bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors
l'italie ouvre ses frontières on vient
de le dire aux touristes européens
alors selon vous est ce que c'est le bon
moment
peut-être on pourra jamais savoir
vraiment bien si c'est vraiment la vidéo
mais oui n'oublions pas que les cas de
koné dan italie ont totalement chuté
fortement depuis hier par exemple vous
n'avez que quelques centaines fait on
n'a que trois cent dix huit nouveaux cas
ont mis il ya encore cinquante cinq
décès mais quand à l'auteur du pays fait
qu' il est tout à fait possible nous
couvrir sachant que quand même les
passages même dit région à l'autre pour
le moment on a vite va y avoir que ça
que des déplacements fondamentalement
région à l'autre d italie donc on va
assister plutôt à un tourisme interne on
va commencer à voir la présence de
certains touristes étrangers mais quand
mon avis ça va être fortement limité il
faut se déplacer mais avec toutes les
mesures nuque a donc dans certains
régions vous savez obligé de vous faire
enregistrer
il n'y a pas de passeport sanitaire donc
nous avaient pas l'obligation de
démontrer quoi que ce soit mais quand
vous descendez d'un avion part bien sûr
vous prendre à une température quand
vous descendez d'un train haute vitesse
bien sûr on vous prendra une débâcle si
vous avez plus de taxis on vous fera le
tampon et dans la région des pouilles
par exemple sur la côte adriatique dans
le sud
si vous devez vous arrivez à l'hôtel ou
dans une maison que vous avez loué vous
êtes obligé de vous déclarer auprès de
la municipalité où vous vous trouvez
même si vous n'avez rien de tout mais il
faut quand même ce décret dont il ya
certaines mesures et il faudra voir
comment va réagir mais comme votre
journaliste validation des portages le
tourisme est forte important l'italie je
dirais même un resserrement des plus
importants secteurs
il est vraiment pas possible de
continuer à le garder complètement
fermée les mesures de confinement ont
tué en effet dévastateur sur le secteur
du tourisme italien qui représente
environ 13% du pib on l'a dit mais
peut-on chiffrer ses pertes pour le
tourisme en particulier
et la croissance en général sans doute
de là on parle de quelques milliards
désormais que pour les revenus des gens
qui travaillent dans le secteur du
tourisme
donc je vous laisse imaginer les
secteurs autour du tourisme
n'oublions pas que beaucoup
d'investissement avait été fait dans
certaines villes à je rappelle que l'une
des villes symboliques ces séries qui a
fait tout un tas d'investissement sur sa
côte et sur ses plages
aujourd'hui se retrouvent complètement
déserté par un secteur qui est
absolument fondamentale donc il s'agit
d'un coût de plusieurs milliards d'euros
pour cette année gens d'une manière
directe pour ne pas parler
je rappelle qu'au signe reste donc c'est
vrai c'est un secteur très important 13
% de notre pib c'est pas peu c'est
beaucoup et on ne sait pas quand cela va
râler parce que le rire ne veut pas dire
avoir vraiment le même revenu
le gouverneur de la région de venice de
la vénétie par exemple demandé le sens
pouces honda les mouettes à sport1
commun qui était absolument impossible
on ne peut pas le faire à ce moment au
musée le musée colonies par exemple
pouvoir le musée de pinocchio en toscane
il a réouvert il accepte que 10
personnes à la fois
imaginez vous les musées du vatican
qu'on y va à réunir 1 définitivement est
complètement avant de pouvoir arriver à
accueillir la même quantité à mon amie
on va devoir attendre l'année prochaine
donc c'est un secteur que a eu déjà une
perte géante de plusieurs milliards
d'euros et qui va retrouver un équilibre
non pas dans les semaines voire quelques
mois à venir mais à mon avis
copieusement au delà de la fin de 2020
donc il faudra attendre le printemps le
printemps de l'année prochaine peut-être
les vacances de noël de cette année
pouvoir retrouver un secteur capable de
revenir à 100% si jamais on va revenir
en force dans ce contexte également la
compagnie aérienne alitalia qui va être
nationalisée en raison de ses
difficultés entend accélérer la reprise
de ses vols ce mois de juin avec une
hausse de saigner
36% par rapport au mois de mai est ce la
seule solution pour la sauver alitalia
c'est un gros dilemme je pense d'avoir
connu mon adolescence avec alitalia a
sauvé donc vous comprenez bien que c'est
toute une histoire déjà très compliquée
pour la compagnie qui a eu des moments
très phase très glorieux
et c'est une compagnie fondamental pour
un pays qui est basé comme vous l'avez
dit sur le tourisme donc oui il faut
quand même investir à c'est pratiquement
la nationaliser on n'a vraiment pas trop
le choix
quitte à se priver d'une compagnie
aliens que cela veut dire ne pas pouvoir
avoir la moindre stratégie de
développement et d'intégration sur
l'ambiance régionales ou
intercontinentales pour ce pays
donc oui il faut intervenir on n'a pas
trop le choix
la question fondamentale c'est pas
tellement le choix d'investir de raids
re-nationaliser alitalia je vous
rappelle que la france a littéralement
nationalisé en france à partir du moment
où vous tenez vous décroche un chèque de
7 milliards d'euros
vous avez acheté la compagnie d'alès
d'un état dans laquelle elle se trouvait
donc à l'italien rossi et la partie au
gouvernement la question est de dire y
at-il dans la cabine de pilotage du
gouvernement italien
un pilote capable de définir la ligne de
développement pour le pays
par rapport aux transports
internationaux s'il n'ya ça alors on
décide un management adapté à cela la
question est de se dire est ce que on
est conscient de ce qu'on veut de cette
compagnie aérienne merci beaucoup vous
vous ep bettoni merci pour toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue à l'université tor vergata
de rome